SPEAKER: Today we're
talking about coding
AI and security best practices.
I'm [INAUDIBLE],, and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
It can be difficult to
disseminate best practices
to developers in
your organization.
But this is critical if you
want to save valuable time
for your business.
To improve this, we are excited
to introduce custom samples
in Cloud Code, our
family of IDE plug-ins
helping you easily distribute
your best practices directly
to your developers'
environments.
Head over to the blog
to learn more about how
Cloud Code helps developers
increase their productivity.
To help organizations
confidently
move their sensitive
data to the Cloud,
Google Cloud works diligently
to earn and maintain
customer trust.
Control and transparency
are pillars of our approach
to offering a trusted Cloud.
We're happy to announce that
Forrester Research has named
Google Cloud a leader in
unstructured data security
platforms.
To learn more, check
out the blog posts.
Ransomware, a form
of malware that
encrypts a user's or
organization's most important
files or data, rendering
them unreadable,
isn't a novel threat in the
world of computer security.
Our commitment to being
the most trusted cloud also
is an ongoing job.
So we've created a
post to share guidance
on how organizations can
increase the resilience
to ransomware, and how some of
our cloud products and services
can help.
At Google I/O, we announced
the general availability
of Vertex AI, a managed
ML platform that
requires about 80% fewer lines
of code to train a model,
and allows companies to
accelerate the deployment
and maintenance of their
artificial intelligence AI
models.
Vertex AI is a single
platform with every tool
you'll need, allowing you to
manage your data, prototype,
experiment, deploy models,
interpret models, and monitor
them in production without
requiring formal ML training.
Check out the blog post for more
exciting news about Vertex AI
and even more from I/O.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.